this was a World Cup journey that few
had predicted would get this far when it
came down to it nobody wanted it to end
here England had waited 28 years to get
this far in the tournament and fans
savored every moment not since it
Hallion 90 and the tears of Paul
Gascoigne had they been so close to a
World Cup final
Croatia stood between England and a
place in Sunday's decider against France
they got off to an incredible start 1
nil up after just four minutes thanks to
a stunning free kick from Kieran trippy
a the fans could scarcely believe what
they were seeing
England ahead in the semi-final of a
World Cup for the first time since 1966
Croatia came back stronger in the second
half and equalized when even Paris each
sneaked in to make it 1-1 it finished
1-1 and went to extra time where Mario
Mandzukic popped up with the winner 2-1
to Croatia the heartbreak of penalties
was at least avoided after four
fantastic weeks in Russia there was
simply no disguising this heartbreak you
know at the moment we all feel the pain
of the defeat did we expect to be in
this position you know I don't think
realistically any of us did but
certainly I'm I'm hugely proud of what
they've done
I couldn't have asked them to give any
more for me or for the country and they
have you know broken through a number of
barriers over the last few weeks and so
it ends for England in heartbreak and
other dreams shattered but if there is
one saving grace is that this team is
young enough to come again I'm prouder
than the empower young team four years
time you know two rows two years welcome
four years old draw but fall cause we're
a better team tonight
[Music]
first time in 28 years semi-final a
young squad IV this were hats officers
of every single one of them so another
significant victory for Croatia this
will be their first time ever playing in
a World Cup final
they will make tough competition for
France who are the hot favorites England
will now face Belgium in a third place
play-off on Saturday in st. Petersburg
it is the game nobody wants to play but
there is undoubtedly more to come from
this vibrant young England team and the
Brady Sky News at Lowe's Nicky Stadium
in Moscow
[Music]